for untold millennia the great
rainforests of Central America have been
kept alive by one of the Tiny's and
least understood of creatures but now
their fragile world has been invaded by
an alien species from Africa the result
of a scientific experiment gone horribly
wrong one man entomologist David Rubik
believes he's imported African bees are
edging out the native honeybees and
damaging the rainforests he's searching
for evidence at stake here is the future
of the rainforests of America's heart
and soul of the Maine
blazing its pollinators and the things
that make all the plants reproduce
it all started in Brazil in 1957
scientists were studying an aggressive
type of bee from Africa when a few of
them escaped it was a mistake
it would have enormous consequences the
African bees proved extremely adaptable
to their new home their numbers soared
and they form voracious swarms that
spread throughout South America and up
to the southwestern United States easily
agitated
and quick to attack they were dubbed
killer bees known to sting humans to
deck swarms react faster than other
honeybees and had been known to chase
victims for a quarter of a mile the
Rubik says they pose a far greater
threat to the fragile rainforest than
they do to people this is one of the
millions bees have done something no
other bee ever did these things have
sucked up most of the resources that are
out there for bees and for other animals
too not just bees as it flowers for food
for
that's butterflies other things take the
same food
and it's not just here and there it's
really everywhere all the vast forest
areas we think of his absolute wildlife
preserves have been violated by this V
this P doesn't belong in any of them
it lives in all of them it's not going
to go away
can native South American honeybees
survive the onslaught of their killer
cousins
abandoned native bee nest suggests it's
a losing battle
the disturbing reality is that it is not
a natural part of this community
yet it has become part of nature and
ironically man has put it there but man
can't take it away
no one knows if the native bees will
survive the alien onslaught or
ultimately perish but Rubik intends to
continue monitoring the fate of this
little lady it's been a staple of the
rain forest since the time of the
Ancients
you